- Do you know what the most iconic formula
in Microsoft Excel for
aspiring consultants is?
This formula or more precisely
combination of formulas
is so well known, so
ubiquitous in consulting,
there are tons of memes on all
the consulting meme channels out there
just about this formula in Excel.
And this formula or
combination of formulas
is of course index-match.
Index-match is a formula in Excel,
which is often used by more competent,
more senior consultants
to divide the cohort
of consultants into the beginners
and those that are a bit more advanced,
specifically when it comes to Excel.
Index-match is considered a bit of
a more advanced formula
combination in Excel,
and many new joiners in consulting
do not really know how to use it.
So if this is true for you as well,
do not worry no more, I will
show you how index-match works.
I will show you in detail
how the formula is working,
and then also put together a
simple little Excel exercise,
based on a financial modeling situation
and show you how you could
resolve it with index-match.
Welcome to another coffee
break with me here on
my channel, Firm Learning.
This is the place where I want
to help you to be successful
in the first years of your career.
As always, if you took any
value out of this video
at all, please hit the like
button for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my
channel to stay up to date.
I release the one video
every week on Saturdays.
But let's now jump into it,
what is index-match and why is it
so important for consultants?
So as there's more motivation,
that's just check out these
hilarious index-match memes.
And if I just type in
index-match meme in Google,
then here in the picture search,
you can all ready see
your whole lot of memes
just around this topic of index-match.
I just pre-opened here a couple of them,
let's go over them.
So here Vlookup no and index-match, yes.
This is what you want to go
for in indeed index-match
is often contrasted with Vlookup
and then Vlookup is often
then considered the beginner,
the new version of the formula,
whereas the real pros
are using index-match.
A bit similar to that is
this one here is a Vlookup,
no thank you, but index-match
is what you need to do.
The next one Excel user index-match,
Vlookup again, the rivalry
between index-match and Vlookup,
of course, index-match is what
is considered superior here.
And yes, then the consultants
are able of doing index-match,
sometimes consider themselves
of super professional Excel users.
And then finally here just
a comparison of Vlookup
and index-match, so
Vlookup is super popular,
whereas index-match is not so much,
and probably the main reason
why Vlookup is so popular
is because it's much easier to use,
but actually index-match
is much more powerful,
it's much more flexible in
the way how you can use it,
and it's also much more
error prone in many ways.
And also it is faster.
So Excel takes less time to calculate,
and probably this was something
that was even more relevant
in the past and not so much
with the newer versions
of Excel, but the
index-match is considered
a more and better performing
version of a lookup.
But now enough with these jokes,
let's now understand how
you can use index-match.
Let's learn how it really works.
And I will contrast it with Vlookup,
just to make sure that you
understand the differences.
And the business setting,
the business application
that I wanna have here
is a little small exercise,
and this is something
that you could easily
then also be exposed to
in any financial modeling
type of situation.
Now, here we are facing the situation
that we are a retail company,
we have a number of stores.
So now I just gave a unique
number to every store.
So these are pretty much in
all the names of the stores.
And now each of these stores
had a forecast for the year.
So for the next year,
there is a company plan
and these are the values
that these stores are supposed to make.
But now you want to break
down these yearly targets
to the individual monthly values, okay?
And you wanna do that
by pretty much applying
the historic distribution of
the revenues across the months.
And let's not just assume that somebody
from the finance department
put together for each
of these stores, here now you
can see that they are orders.
These are now the exact certain
stores that we saw before.
Here we put together what the
percentage of the revenues are
that accrue in the individual months,
based on historic figures.
So how this distribution
was in the prior years.
And then you always see that
the total for each line is 100.
So this is always the sum of these values,
but you can see that the
distribution is quite different.
So for instance,
store number one made 18.8%
of the revenues in January,
whereas store number two,
made 7% of the revenues in January.
And now we need to do the following.
Mainly we need to match apply this number
with the corresponding
percentage of the historic split.
And this is something
were you would usually use
a lookup four.
And so what you need here
is a 2-dimensional lookup
to pretty much picking the
right value for the store
and for the month.
So 2-dimension lookup.
So let's now start by looking
into how this would work
with Vlookup and now I
would assume that you have
an understanding of how Vlookup works.
If you don't, then please just look it up,
there are many resources on that online.
I will later explained
index-match in much more detailed,
but Vlookup just as a basic comparison.
And what most people will do,
I can tell you from my experience,
if they would need to
do something like this,
they will type in
Vlookup, they choose here
the lookup value, then here you fix now
of course the columns.
Then you need to choose
then the table array.
So this is always the first
table here the reference,
the D numbers, and then
here they choose the columns
that are relevant, here are 13 columns.
And now for January,
they then put the number
two because this is then
the second column and then an exact match.
And then what you have here,
this is now a percentage value, right?
But what you have here is 0.09,
which should be the value from
January for store number six.
So let's check store number six.
January is 8.7.
So I assume if you just take
one more digit, yeah 8.7,
this is not the percentage
figure that we got earlier.
But now of course the downside is
even if I now fix this reference here,
if I want to now have it for
February for the next month,
if I just copy it over, it doesn't work
because those two, this
number is not dynamic,
but here for February, I
would need a three, right?
So the next column in the
historical split table
to really make use of that.
It's actually what I have seen people do
was that then they would actually
just manually type in here
a three and here a four and so on
just to get all the
monthly values correct.
So let's just check here
for six, eight, seven,
13.2, so this fits, and then here 12.7,
so this fits as well,
but of course typing
all of this in manually
of course, isn't really the way to go.
No of course not, maybe for the 12 here
it might even work, but now
imagine having to do this
for a much larger table,
with many more columns,
then it just wouldn't
be able to handle it.
And then what some maybe a
bit smarter people would do
is that they would include
something like a helper line here
were then instead of writing the two out,
they would just link it here
and then basically do it like this.
And now of course you have
the advantage of being able
to automate it in some ways.
But now what do you do if
for whatever reason here
a new column gets inserted?
Because now this doesn't work anymore
because now the fifth
column here is empty,
whereas you want to have the
value for April in the column
here for April, right?
And so for all these kinds of reasons,
using Vlookup in the classical setup
just doesn't make a lot of sense,
and it's just not recommended
and it's just not really
considered professional.
And this is now really where
index-match comes into play.
So how does index-match work?
And before we now dive
into the numbers here,
let me try to give you a bit more
of an intuitive explanation
into all of this.
So index-match is a
combination of two formulas.
It's a combination of the index formula,
which is then combined
with the match formula.
So how do these two
formulas work together?
And how it works is that
in the index formula,
you define an array.
So basically you define
a range of a table,
so certain reference which
can be somewhere in the middle
of an Excel sheet that
is now the new range
where the formula looks into.
And now, so applying this to
this historical split table
that we used, here we had all
the numbers of the stores.
So from one to five and
turn the very end, 30,
and then on this axis, you
had January, February, March,
April, and so on.
And now what the match formula
does is it looks both into
the rows and also into
the columns and saying,
okay, return to me what
number here is, for instance,
the store number three.
And now, because this is ordered,
the store number three also
comes into the third position
in this array.
And the same is now true
for the second match formula
that we will use to now
pull up the columns,
and here again now for it
it could look into, okay,
what number in this array is
actually the month of April.
And here now, the way
we have set it up here,
it would be one, two, three, four, right?
And then it can give me
pretty much the number three
in the rows and the
number four in the columns
to them put up this exact value.
So this is how you use it,
and I can understand that now
this was a bit hard to follow,
but let's now jump into
the practical example
to really bring this to life.
And we now start by setting
up the index formula.
And here now this is now the
index for the store number six,
but first we need to define the array.
So the overall table that
now the values are supposed
to be pulled out.
And here we now just mark
this data table here.
So now I just made a
reference here from A3 to N33,
just to mark this whole
table here and I fix it.
So now we have the whole array defined.
So this is now the
overall field from rich X
and I will pull out individual numbers.
And now it asks for a row
number and for a column number.
So how this works is that
now the very first field
of this array, and here you
see it starts at the field A3.
This now has the row number
one and the column number one.
So this is field one, one.
This one here, one below, this
would be the row number two,
because there are two rows
and then still the column one.
This field here for instance,
this would be the row
number one, two, three,
and then the column number
one, two, three, four.
So three, four would
give us in this field.
So that's not just do an example
for the store six, January
that we just had selected.
And now for January,
this would be the number
that we would want to pull out, right?
So the 8.7%.
And this now would pretty
much mean row number of seven.
So this is the seventh row, right?
So one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven.
So for the row number,
here is asking you for,
we type in the seven and
then for the column number,
because this is January,
this is the second column,
so we type in here the second column.
And now this is all ready what we have.
And if we now type this in,
then of course we get
exactly this number 8.7%.
And this was this number
here that we wanted.
So far, so good.
But now of course you
want to make this dynamic
because now you would
have the same problem
as if you would just use the
Vlookup in the prior example,
and what you want to use here instead
are now the match formulas.
So both of these two numbers,
both the column and the row look up,
needs to be replaced by a match formula.
And let's just start
here by the row number.
So we pull up the match formula
and now he looks for a lookup value,
and in the rows, you remember
that we had the stores.
So we now highlight here the store value,
we fix the columns to be able
to now always look up here
the stores in every field.
Now it asks for a lookup
error for the match.
And now all you need to
highlight the exact column
from the exact length as
you also did for the array.
So you see regarding the
rows that the rows go
from three to 33.
So now here is where you need to create
a match lookup array that
has the same kind of size,
namely A3 to A33.
And then the match type is zero.
So let's now see if
this was done correctly,
because if it did it should
still now give us the 8.7
and it does, right, it
still gives us the 8.7%,
or Euro because it's formatted
as a Euro value, 0.087.
And now let's just check
just to double, triple check
if this is really the case,
if we evaluate this expression
and you can always do that by pressing F9,
if you press F9 on such a thing,
it returns the value that
then the certain formula
within a formula is actually returning.
So if I press F9 I can see that
this whole match expression
is returning the value seven,
which is exactly the one that
we expected it to return.
So just explain it again.
Why is this returning a seven?
Because the match formula as we had here,
it now gives a certain range
as we now have to find it here
from A3 to A33, this is how we set it up.
So from here to here,
this is what we gave as a lookup value.
And now it takes this value here,
this here defined the value six,
it now goes into this range
and it looks for this value six, right?
So it looks in this range
where is the value six?
And now of course it finds it here,
and now it returns the relative position
of this element in this lookup area.
So now starting at the top,
it counts one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
So it says, okay, this
value that I found here,
this value six is the seventh number,
the seventh item in this lookup area.
And this of course now is exactly
what do you want it to do,
right, because we want to know what number
it is regarding the rows,
and this is exactly what the
match formula is returning.
And as we all ready
know, this is now seven,
which is right, returns a seven.
So now when let's do the
same thing for the columns,
and again, we use instead of
now manually writing it in,
match for it returning the column figure.
And we do that again for us
by providing the lookup value.
And now in the columns,
it's the months, right?
So you wanna look up the
months in the new lookup area.
So, you now highlight or
select this January thing,
and now you fixed the row.
And now next you define the
lookup area or the lookup array.
And this is now a here,
this one, and again,
you need to go over the same size exactly
how your overall index array was set up,
and you'll see that this was
going from column A to column N
so here you now need
to make sure that this
is now going from column A to column N
to really make these arrays match, right?
So that now the first, second,
third, fourth, et cetera,
position of this array is
the same as the number of,
regarding the positions of the columns
of the overall array that you
defined here for the index.
So let's now fix that as well.
And let's now again, do the match type,
and this is supposed to be
always zero and exact match.
And now, again, it stays
at the same number.
So this seems to be correct.
And if we not evaluate
this second match formula,
it returns a two.
And this of course is
exactly what we wanted to do.
So again, how does this work?
Here we gave the January
as the lookup value,
then here we defined the array,
and now it looks into this array
what position starting here from the left
is this value that he's looking for,
mainly this Jan, the January value.
And now here, you can actually
see that it's the second one
from the left, so it returns
the number or the index two.
Now with these two lookup values,
pretty much the row index
and the column index,
we can then really look up
exactly this precise percentage
that we were looking for.
And now of course the
beauty is if we fixed
all of this correctly, and
I all ready see that here,
now we haven't fix this property,
so let's just check this
is fully fixed here,
the column is fixed, this is
fixed here, the rows are fixed,
and this is fixed, so it should be fine.
If we now copy it over.
So it should be now able to directly give
the correct numbers here everywhere.
And this all ready looks quite good.
So let's just check by
including some values,
because now every row should
return the number one.
So I just included here
the sums for every row,
because of course these
were a percentage figures,
and now the sum of all these
percentages should add up
to a 100% or the number one?
So let's just pick up
the row 22 as a check
and here the store 22, you
see it starts with 1.0,
this is exactly what you have here.
One of 14.2, this is what you have here.
Then the last one is 6.9.
So yes, it did seem to give
us the correct values here.
So now you directly
filled all the percentages
with this index-match
technique and now I've crossed
the last thing that you wanna do
is that you wanna
multiply this whole thing,
with the revenue of the
total yearly revenue target
in order to now get the
actual targets that you have.
And now you do that by multiplying it
and fixing the columns.
And if you do that, you can
kind of pretty much start
to see that now some numbers
come up that look good.
So now just to make these better readable,
let's just work with
these little things here
and now what you can all ready see
is that now here are the total adds up
to exact same number as this total here,
which is of course correct,
so this is exactly how
it's supposed to be.
So let just triple check
by adding a sum here,
and then also adding the
same sum function over
this range here, and now, yes, you can see
that it adds up to the very
same number as it should.
So this is how it works, this
is how you use index-match,
and just going back to the
example that we had earlier,
if we now here start adding
a new column, for instance,
or even several new columns,
all of this should not be bothered at all
because we made this as a reference.
Now, again, it includes
automatically all the ranges.
So you can see that instead of
going from A to N as before,
now, it just goes from A to
P, so just expanded that.
And because it doesn't care
about the absolute value here,
with the match, you just
directly pull up the right index.
And of course you could have also included
the match function in your
Vlookup to do that instead.
But then if you start doing that,
then why not directly using index-match
and get the other benefits
like the performance
improvements this way.
So hope that this was helpful.
So the bottom line is that
pretty much when ever you wanna
use a 2-dimensional lookup, in most cases
using an index match is the way to go.
And even with only a
one dimensional lookup,
there can be reasons,
but then you would choose an index-match
over just the Vlookup.
Of course, there are good
reasons to look Vlookup as well,
probably just easier to set
up, just a bit more convenient
and probably even the biggest
pros are still using Vlookup,
if they just quickly wanna do something,
even though maybe they just
claim or pretend they don't.
But I mean, it's okay, right.
But just be aware when
you use it and be aware
of the disadvantages and
all that this really helps
to step up your Excel
skills, because index-match
is something that requires a bit more
of an advanced understanding.
But once you got it,
once you understand it,
then it's still pretty quick
and pretty easy to set up.
And so I hope that I was
able to teach you the basics
that you have now this
basic understanding.
And can incorporate index-match
into your Excel tool kit as well.
So I hope you found this helpful
and this really helped you
to use and apply index-match
for your own Excel models.
As always, if you have any questions,
please leave a comment below
in the comment section,
I will do my very best to
answer every single one.
If you took any value out of this video,
please destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe, and also
turn the notifications on
with the bell icon to make sure
that you really see every
single video of myself.
If you want to see even
more content like that,
you can also follow me on my Instagram,
my handle is Firmlearning,
and also do not forget to
sign up for my email list.
You can find a link to the sign up form
in my video description.
Thank you guys for watching.
I really appreciate your time
and I hope you got some value
out of this video.
The next video will be
released next Saturday.
So stay tuned for that and until then,
keep learning and have a good weekend.